[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de Francia 24 en
Colombia la comisión de la verdad en
nacida de los acuerdos con la extinta
guerrilla de las FARC que publicó el
capítulo de mujer y género como parte
del informe final que recoge los
hallazgos o es de más de tres años de
escuchas y análisis de lo ocurrido
durante casi seis décadas de guerra en
el país el documento titulado mi cuerpo
es la verdad experiencias de mujeres y
personas
lgbtiq más en el conflicto armado
evidenció los testimonios de más de
10.000 mujeres en tres años de
investigaciones la inmensa mayoría de
las víctimas están entre los 12 y los 28
años fueron más de 12.000 eventos de
violencias sexuales perpetrados por
grupos o como los paramilitares que
efectuaron una violación acoso la
obligación de presenciar actos sexuales
la desnudez forzada la esclavitud sexual
y la amenaza de violación entre otros
todo esto como una estrategia de guerra
para inculcar terror en contra de las
comunidades y para tener control
territorial
la guerra de sacerdotes
proporcionadamente los efectos contra
las mujeres vamos a conversar sobre este
tema y sobre las conclusiones desde el
informe para ello nos acompaña en el
Salomé Gómez Corrales quienes
coordinadora del grupo de trabajo de
género de la comisión de la verdad Y
también está con nosotros el linda
Cabrera ella es directora de la
corporación o el cisma mujer una de las
organizaciones que participó con la
comisión de la verdad para llegar hasta
este informe final gracias a ambas por
estar con nosotros en ella soy y vamos a
entrar en materia Salomé las mujeres y
niñas entre los 12 y los 28 años
representan nada más y nada menos que
92,5% de más de 32 mil víctimas en actos
que atentaron contra la libertad y
contra la integridad sexual la mayoría
de estas mujeres y niñas son población
rural son décadas y décadas de maltrato
y solamente hasta hace poco la
jurisdicción especial para la paz abrió
dos son macrocazos enfocados en
violencia sexuales y en otros crímenes
de género salo que esperan ustedes de
estas audiencias
Bueno pues muchas gracias por esta
invitación Ángela para nosotros es muy
importante de poder hablar y presentar
los resultados de nuestro informe de mi
cuerpo es la verdad quiero decir que
este volumen que habla sobre lo que le
ha pasado a las mujeres y personas lgbt
es un insumo fundamental para el proceso
que
funciona en especial para la paz
justo coincide con la apertura
ocupacional
extrajudicial es un análisis detallado
de lo que le ha pasado a las mujeres en
este caso especialmente sobre las
violencias sexuales y reproductivas
muestra las diferencias de los infantes
impactos entonces
muy bien Salomé Ya regreso con usted
para más preguntas Hacer una aclaración
para nuestros televidentes Salomé está
en este momento en territorio por lo
tanto las comunicaciones son un poco
difíciles y están en este trabajo de
divulgar este informe este capítulo de
género Así que vamos a continuar con la
conversación con Linda Cabrera que es la
directora de la corporación no es sismo
mujer linda la misma pregunta para usted
qué es lo que esperan ustedes que pase a
partir de todo esta movilización
feminista durante tres años para
investigar para conversar con las
mujeres y para obtener los testimonios
que nos permitan hallar finalmente algo
de reparación y de justicia
Bueno buenas buenas buenas un saludo
cordial para todas las personas
quisiéramos desde las organizaciones de
mujeres realmente que hemos trabajado
aportando informes reconstruyendo los
testimonios de las mujeres para este
trabajo que ha presentado la comisión de
la verdad el lograr varias cosas primero
visibilizar esas realidades lo primero
sea decir que este informe no es un
capítulo no es una parte específico sino
que es la verdad el 50% de la población
luego es un informe de los principales
que tiene que tener el mayor
protagonismo en esta labor de la
comisión de la verdad y debería llamar
la atención de manera prioritaria de
toda la sociedad para saber qué pasó con
el 50% de la población en el marco de
conflicto los segundos que quisiéramos
en el marco de esa visibilización lograr
transmitir mensajes de los que la
comisión ha construido que creo que muy
valiosamente en este en este informe que
estaba que ha presentado el día de ayer
es la construcción realmente construida
Perdón elaborada desde el enfoque de
género que da cuenta de los efectos de
la militarización en la vida de las
mujeres y las niñas de los efectos de la
fumigación por el tema de las drogas de
los efectos en la salud de los efectos
psicosociales tiene un importante
énfasis en violencia sexual que ha sido
una de las principales y graves
violaciones de Derechos Humanos que han
sufrido las mujeres y las niñas en el
territorio se atribuye responsabilidad a
los diferentes actores armados que es
algo que las organizaciones hemos
enfatizado muchísimo y también tiene una
lectura muy desde la perspectiva
feminista que también es muy valiosa
para nosotras sobre las estructuras de
poder que generaron esas riesgos
diferenciales y esos efectos
desproporcionados de la guerra en la
vida y los cuerpos de las mujeres te
habla explícitamente de las estructuras
patriarcales y es muy importante que
digamos que un informe desde la
institucionalidad recoja Este lenguaje
que es un aporte de la teoría feminista
y también se hayan brindado
recomendaciones sobre la necesidad de
revisar y de reconfigurar esas
estructuras patriarcales de poder que
son las que mantienen a las mujeres en
esas condiciones digamos de mayor riesgo
frente a escenarios de conflicto y
escenarios digamos de crisis en general
Bueno este 21 de Julio fue la fecha
elegida para que se diera se diera una
voz a todas estas mujeres y para que
estos testimonios empezaran a hacerse
reconocidos en un trabajo de memoria muy
importante Pues en este en esta etapa
del país del posconflicto y en el
informe y en los artículos periodísticos
redactados en Francia 24 se recalca que
los cuerpos de las mujeres fueron
utilizados para controlar los
territorios y ahí yo le quiero preguntar
linda por qué Porque el cuerpo de la
mujer es utilizado como una herramienta
de guerra
el control territorial es un patrón de
victimización de actuación de los
actores armados en el informe se habla
sobre la manera como los actores armados
premeditadamente y a través de una
estrategia deliberada planeada en ese
sentido
sabían que para controlar los
territorios tenían que controlar los
cuerpos y las vías de las mujeres llegan
las mujeres tienen una radio
importantísimo en las comunidades en los
territorios porque son cuidadoras de
vida son cuidadoras también de las
comunidades ejercen un rol
importantísimo y la forma de lograr
entre otras entre otras objetivos ese
control territorial fue dominar a las
mujeres una mujer violentada sexualmente
era una mujer que seguramente se iba a
desplazar entonces lograban tener
control territorial o si no se
desplazaba iban a tener el control
digamos El dominio y relación con el
miedo que genera ese tipo de conductas Y
entonces iba a haber obediencia de
quienes se quedarán en los territorios
es una forma digamos
de controlar y de dominar esas
comunidades esos territorios a través de
las mujeres entre muchas estrategias que
utilizaron los actores armados muy bien
Ahora Quisiera regresar y la
comunicación nos lo permite Salomé
hablemos un poco por favor de las
modalidades de violencia que se
ejercieron durante estas décadas de
violencia y que ustedes han podido
recopilar en este capítulo de género de
la comisión de la verdad
Ángela nuevamente sí como tú lo decías
es todo el justo desde él zona rural del
departamento del cauca socializando
nuestros primeros hallazgos de el
volumen lo primero que quisiera decir es
que las mujeres han sufrido todas las
capitalizaciones han sufrido el
desplazamiento el despojo de sus tierras
La amenaza la desaparición que han
vivido especialmente son las principales
víctimas sexuales y eso sumado vuelvo a
decir a las otras violencias decía no
son las únicas violencias que han vivido
sino que están en intersección y se
profundizan esto es muy gravemente para
una sociedad y de eso también quisiera
decir que hay un hallazgo muy importante
en nuestro volumen Y es que también
mostramos el continuum de violencias que
han vivido las mujeres es decir que han
vivido no solamente en el marco del
conflicto armado sino que también los
han vivido previamente en sus espacios
más
cotidianos posterior al conflicto
armados como sociedad no avanzamos en la
eliminación y erradicación por las
mujeres no en paz viene y linda hablando
sobre estos hallazgos que se hicieron y
sobre este amplio registro de más de
10.000 mujeres que fueron entrevistadas
y cuyos testimonios fueron recogidos sin
embargo quedan sin sabor y ese el del
surestro que nunca podremos saber a
ciencia cierta de cuánto es Pero cómo lo
estiman ustedes dentro de todas estas
mujeres y niñas que no se atreven o no
conocen sus derechos y ese
reconocimiento que deben tener por haber
sido Víctimas de la violencia en el
contexto de una guerra interna
si en efecto Hay demasiadas voces
silenciadas de hecho ya no solo por el
temor y el miedo que genera hablar de
nuestros temas para muchas víctimas sino
porque no pues muchas No superaron esas
victimizaciones y muchas fueron
asesinadas entonces hay muchos silencios
que definitivamente se van a mantener
Pero recuerdo las palabras de muchas
mujeres que nosotros hemos acompañado y
que han dicho si si mi testimonio he
recogido en la comisión de la verdad de
alguna manera esa es una forma de hablar
por todas Sí y de hablar por todas esas
víctimas mujeres y niñas en el conflicto
y Mostrar qué fue lo que sucedió con
todas Entonces yo creo que lo que ha
hecho la comisión de la verdad es
dignificar la memoria de todas las
víctimas de todas las mujeres y niñas
víctimas independientemente de que solo
se recojan algunos testimonios o algunos
elementos claramente es una forma de de
contar Qué ha pasado con todas las
mujeres y también de alguna manera
resignificar y dignificar esos otros
silencios de quienes ya definitivamente
no no han decidido hablar o ya no pueden
hacerlo bueno linda y además esto se
graba cuando uno comienza a mirar el
tema de las transversalidades que
mencionaba hace un momento Salomé las
mujeres afectadas son mujeres Rurales
son mujeres indígenas mujeres
afrodescendientes mujeres diversas y una
amplísima comunidad de niñas que fueron
violentadas cómo se curan
estas heridas que dejan la guerra estos
maltratos lo hemos dicho muchas veces en
ellas soy el crimen de la violación es
comparable al crimen de la asesinato
entonces pues claro es muy importante
hacer esta tarea de verdad y de
reparación y de memoria para reconocer
que estas víctimas existen Pero además
de eso que que puede hacer o que debe
hacer el estado por todas estas mujeres
Víctimas de violencia sexual y de otro
tipo de atrocidades en la guerra
Sí pues el derecho a la verdad es uno de
los componentes que previó este acuerdo
de paz para garantizar los derechos a la
de la verdad justicia reparación de las
diferentes víctimas y claramente es uno
solo de los componentes es necesario que
operen los demás en términos de
reparación en términos de acceso a la
justicia y realmente se garantiza este
enfoque de integralidad que prohibió el
acuerdo de paz para responder a estas
víctimas sin embargo También es
importante que en el marco del informe
se reconozca que lo que ha sucedido es
una expresión de discriminación y
violencia histórica contra las mujeres
como lo decía Salomé es una es un
continuum de violencias lo que ha
sucedido en el marco del conflicto
armado es siempre una representación y
un reflejo de lo que sucede en todos los
escenarios de violencias por eso lo
principal que tiene que hacer el estado
para enfrentar y para remediar ese tipo
de situaciones y sobre todo para que no
se vuelvan a repetir ese enfrentar el
panorama estructural de violencias y
discriminación en contextos contra las
mujeres y contra las niñas para que
estos hechos no se repitan bueno en
televisión el tiempo es limitado Gracias
a ustedes por estar con nosotros por el
análisis de la ampliación para nuestros
televidentes la pueden encontrar en
nuestro sitio web de 24.com con el
artículo sobre el tema que escribió
nuestra periodista Marina sardiña eran
entonces a love Gómez Corrales del grupo
de trabajo de género de la comisión de
la verdad y linda Cabrera de la
corporación un sismo mujer Gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros y nos
vemos Próximamente en ella soy
[Música]